hello everybody and welcome to another
moneymaking guide today I'm going to be
showing you how I made
150k in 1 hour of doing this method on
top of that I also got 190k Fletching
experience so it's a really good way to
level up your Fletching and make a
decent amount of bank at the same time
uh has pretty low requirements you will
need 65 Fletching uh you will need some
starting cash though uh roughly around
10 mil uh or maybe even 5 mil would be
good and yeah let's get
started so what we're going to be doing
today is we are going to be creating
Diamond bolts out of adamant bolts and
Diamond bolt tips now this method only
requires 65 Fletching which is uh not
too high actually only took me about 3
or 4 hours to get this High didn't even
cost very much money
realistically and uh you'll need about
10 mil at the start that will give you a
full buy limits worth of the pre
prerequisites so what we're going to do
is first of all we want to check the uh
how profitable it's going to be which is
important to do first so what you need
to do is we're combining Diamond bolt
tips and Adam and bolts so we need to
buy uh and sell one of the diamond bolt
tips so we bought it for 215 and we're
going to sell it
for
203 Next Step we're going to buy the
admin bolt
itself admin
Bolt
uh bought it for 2118 and we can sell it
for
200 and lastly we're going to buy the
diamond
bolt and we bought it for 420 uh so to
calculate the margin it's pretty
simple we're going to take uh what we
can sell it for 420 take off the cost of
the Adam and bolt which is 200 and the
cost of the diamond bolt which is 203 so
we're left with 17 is how much we're
going to profit on each bolt now you can
do about 27,000 of these an hour maybe
25,000
um and that leaves us with
459k in profit that being said if we
have a look at what the diamond bolts
are regularly selling for uh this is
just a bit of a dip where we are now so
the actual the the ingredients for this
might be a bit cheaper because of this
uh but we could probably sell it for 450
pretty reasonably and if we did that
I'll recalculate it for you 450
minus 200 -
203 it's going to be 47 and if we do
27,000 an hour it's a 1.2 mil maybe
closer to 1 mil uh but yeah let's give
this a shot and we'll see how it works
so uh we'll go ahead and just take the
prices here admin bolts and uh we'll buy
them for
200 and do 10k of them
and we'll do the
diamond bolt
tips and sorry how much we're buying
those for 203 and I will do an even 10k
of those uh cuz their buying limits are
11k so keep that in mind when you're
doing this uh it's good to plan ahead
all right we'll come back when these
have bought all right so we actually
bought all the admin bolts and the
diamond bolt tips we had to increase the
price a bit uh they weren't buying so we
increased it a bit left an hour and we
did buy all of them uh so collect those
all up 10,000 and
10,000 now the next step is really easy
all you're going to do is click on one
click on the other and the max you can
do is 10 at a time so it takes about H
10 seconds or something to do
10 and that's it you can kind of AFK
doing this very easily I mean you do
have to pay attention a bit cuz like and
that happens sometimes too make sure you
click on the bolts first or else you
equip them uh but it's really easy and
you don't have to bank or anything it's
just in your inventory and you're just
making these bolts on top of that you
are getting quite a bit of Fletching
experience um also have a quick look at
the side for you here I'll be able to
frame so on top of the money I am
getting about 170 to
190k Fletching experience an hour so
this is an extremely profitable and
quick way to level up your Fletching I
mean when I was doing the maple Cross or
the maple long was to get here I was
probably getting 100 something similar
uh but I was not getting near the amount
of money I am now so uh we'll go ahead
do all these bolts uh we'll time how
long it takes us and then uh we'll come
up with a number for how much you can
get per hour and how much experience you
could expect to get all right we'll be
back in a minute all right guys so the
diamond bolts have totally sold off
unfortunately we had to drop them by
about 10 GP so we sold them for $449
each as opposed to$ 459 uh which did
affect their profit but I think we're
still going to do pretty well uh so
we're going to claim them we sold them
for about 4.5 mil almost
now just to do a quick calculation for
you guys uh well first let's just have a
look at what we're left with so we
started with 10 mil and uh we ended with
about
420k in profit uh which is pretty good
so uh after kind of doing a few
calculations with how long it took me it
took me about 24 minutes to combine all
of these that leaves us with about
25,000 we can combine an hour it's a
nice even number uh so if we just
multiply 420 by 2.5 that's going to give
us just over a m in profit if we were to
do this for an hour just keep in mind
the buying limits do affect this a
little bit but uh for the most part it's
a pretty easy way to make some quick
cash on top of that we ended up with
about
180k Fletching experience that would
have been gained in an hour we
personally got I guess about 95 uh in
the half an hour or so that we did it or
maybe a little less 80 to 90 uh but
still really good especially if you're
wanting to train your Fletching as well
as make some money it's an excellent way
to uh level it up quickly and uh well
make it my money all right I hope you
guys enjoyed and I'll see you guys in
the next
[Music]
episode